so I'm in the cubicle at a marketing
manager for crest who's paid yeah and
I'm like sick of it yes and I want to
break out I you know incomes are going
down I'm worried about my job they're
outsourcing everything at China yes what
what should I start to do the first
thing you should do is you shouldn't
have [ __ ] watched house of cards this
entire [ __ ] Saturday that's the first
thing you should do okay if you complain
and by the way you can make 40,000 a
year and not be complaining so this is
not about how much success you've had
this is complaining this is what was me
I'm in this cubicle cret you're
complaining to yourself and even worse
and I know you guys you're complaining
to others your spouse and girlfriend
your brother
your mom if you were complaining the
first thing that has to happen is the
elimination of Matt in the softball team
house of cards leisure leisure is what
you give up to have the audacity to
build your life that you want so if you
didn't watch house of cards for 13 hours
this weekend it would have given you 13
hours to map out what you're going to do
to get out of that job at crest
yeah Johnny crest he eliminates house of
cards eliminates a softball game he's
ready to go what's next self awareness
I believe that self awareness is the
single best number one attribute anyone
could ever be gifted with and better
than being good looking better than
being super smart self awareness I'm
very comfortable in admitting that I
don't know the science behind self
awareness
I don't know the anthropology or
psychology around and I don't know how
its taught I just know it's the thing
and then you do the assessment and you
take the data and you finally for the
first time in your life Jonny Quest
decide you don't live life hoping and
wishing you or something you start for
the first time in your life actually
deciding what you are and navigating
around that so Johnny Chris does this
now he starts to change he's like okay
they're right I want to do do bigger and
better things in my life what's next
what's the what's the next practical
step cuz that's a good practical step I
think that at that point Johnny kress
wants to decide
if he wants to go for it or not because
I actually think 8 out of 10 times
Johnny crest after that process takes a
step back and says you know what I'd
like to confirm with my buddy on
Thursday night
I like house of cards I think it's kind
of cool and he may then realize huh
I'm actually okay like yeah I'm not
going to be horrible that is not okay
well then he's or not then he decides
what I think back to crusher
he tries to build a business around
something he loves because if he does
that it won't be work Johnny is now 38
did we make him 30 let's make him 38
Johnny fell 30 years and Johnny watches
NASCAR every weekend Johnny does mix
martial art like Johnny has to look at
what he does when he's not working and
build a business around that let's say
Johnny's 15 years of crest let's say
Johnny makes two hundred thirteen
thousand dollars a year right like what
he has to do is decide that is he
willing to make a me $7,000 a year
shitload happier and down trousers home
or not for many vacations these are
choices my man so it seems like you're
always leveraging I have an you're doing
practice next thing I'm scared I'm
practical I don't want to the only
advice I've ever given in my life James
I'm super undereducated I was a DNF
student in high school I've read like
four [ __ ] books and the only advice I
ever give is predicated on things I've
already done let's talk about a couple
things there's a couple things that I
want Johnny crests do in parallel I want
him to create a Twitter account Twitter
even though is struggling and it is
still has a big advantage over every
other platform Johnny crest can
absolutely type in Pokemon or rock and
roll or juicy in Twitter search and see
other people talking about it and I want
him to engage with those people I also
wanted to tweet at Dana White and the
creator of kinky mom's butt and
Pikachu's girl 47 that's the number one
influencer on Twitter and start creating
these relationships on social because
it's part of the narrative in Twitter
they will see that you're reaching out
to young people's 47 they say I'm not
talking aggressed straight if you get 12
times you know rewarding you on that
soon after you start building
relationships and try to build in value
don't hit up Pikachu 47 and say hey
Pikachu 47 tell everybody about my
Johnny crest Amazon account watch
Pikachu 47 and when Pikachu girl 47 says
that she needs something and you happen
to be in that town be like I got you
value first right we have to reprogram
rebrand and relook at entrepreneurship
entrepreneurship is freedom it doesn't
mean making a million dollars it means
freedom
[Music]